>> Shannon: THERE’S SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW.
SO WE ARE TAKING YOUR QUESTION
STRAIGHT TO OUR EXPERTS DOING
THIS EVERY NIGHT.
YOU CAN TWEET US OUR QUESTIONS
AT FOX NEWS NIGHT.
ALSO PART OF THE FOX FAMILY NOW
AND SHE IS A MEDICAL OFFICER AT
HEEL.
THEY CUBA FOR GIVING US TIME
TONIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Shannon: I HAVE A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS THAT I KEEP
COMMONLY GETTING ASKED AND I
WANT TO ASK YOU GUYS ABOUT THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, I KEEP HEARING
PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT IBUPROFEN
AS THEY THINK THEY HAVE THE FLU.
THERE ARE WORRIES AND RUMORS ALL
OVER TWITTER THAT IF YOU TAKE
IBUPROFEN THEY COULD ACTUALLY BE
A NEGATIVE THING.
DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
>> THERE IS ACTUALLY NO STUDIES
TO PROVE THAT.
IF YOU TAKE IBUPROFEN, IT CAN
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR THE VIRUS TO
ENTER THE CELL MORE EASILY.
THIS HASN’T BEEN PROVEN.
I THINK IF YOU TAKE ONE DOSE OR
TWO DOSES IT’S NOT GOING TO MAKE
A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
BUT THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE
WHICH IS ACETAMINOPHEN ALSO
KNOWN AS TYLENOL.
THAT CAN -- AN ADDITION TO
DRINKING LOTS OF FLUIDS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
WE HAVE HEARD IF YOU DO HAVE
WORRIES YOU MAY BE NEED TO GET
TESTED.
CALL YOUR DOCTOR’S OFFICE, BUT
WHAT ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
HOUSECALLS?
SEEMS LIKE AN OLD-SCHOOL WAY OF
DOING THINGS.
OTHER DOCTORS WILL ACTUALLY COME
SEE YOU AND -- WHAT’S THE BEST
WAY TO GO?
>> WE STARTED A COMPANY CALLED
HEEL.
THAT’S THE ENTIRE IDEA.
IF YOU DO HAVE MILD SYMPTOMS,
THE BEST THING TO DO IS STAY AT
HOME.
AND PRESUMABLY IF YOU ARE NOT
FEELING HORRIBLY, YOU DON’T NEED
TO BE TESTED.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOU ARE
FEELING TERRIBLE AND THINK YOU
NEED TO BE TESTED I KNOW THE
BEST THING TO DO IS TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE TO GO TO GET
TESTING.
WE DO DELIVER HOUSECALLS, BUT
WHAT IS BEEN INTERESTING ABOUT
OUR HOUSECALLS SYSTEM IS THAT
FIRST WE HAVE RELEASED MEDICINE
SO THAT WE HAVE ACCESS.
BUT SECOND, THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO SYMPTOMS --
THEY ARE DIABETIC, HYPERTENSIVE.
WHICH IS ESPECIALLY CONCERNING
AT THESE CRAZY TIMES.
SO THESE HOUSECALLS ARE ACTUALLY
HELPING THEM GET THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR CHRONIC
DISEASE.
THAT IS BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF WHAT WE ARE ADDING.
>> SUCH A PERSONAL THING.
ETIQUETTE WOULD GO A LONG WAY
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE ANXIETY OR
TRAPPED AT HOME OR IF YOU LIKE
THEY SHOULDN’T GO OUT.
SO LET’S GET SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS HERE.
FOR SOME REASON INCLUDING
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"."
I THINK ABOUT IS NOW BRINGING IN
MAIL OR BRINGING IN PACKAGES,
WHAT YOU SAY?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE FOR THE VIRUS
AND BACTERIA FUNGUS TO LIVE ON
INANIMATE OBJECTS, SO IF YOU SEE
OBVIOUS DEBRIS THEN YES YOU WANT
TO CLEAN IT OFF.
BUT WHAT’S MOST IMPORTANT IS
AFTER HANDLING A PACKAGE OR
SOMETHING THAT’S DELIVERED TO
YOU OR NEWSPAPER WASH HER HANDS.
IF THAT’S THE NUMBER ONE WAY TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF INFECTION
AND THE BEST THING YOU COULD DO
TO PROTECT YOURSELF.
HAND WASHING.
>> WE HAVE NOW HAD TO BUY A
BUNCH OF HAND LOTION TOO BECAUSE
WE ARE WATCHING A BUNCH MORE.
WE ALL HAVE DRIED OUT, SCALY
SKIN.
CLEVER PATRIOTS.
IF I NEED A MEDICAL REFILL BUT
DON’T WANT TO GO TO MY POSITION,
WHAT DO I DO?
WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND?
>> THIS IS A PERFECT REASON TO
USE OUR APP.
HAVE EITHER A HOUSE CALL DOCTOR,
OR GET A TELEMEDICINE VISIT FOR
REAL.
>> Shannon: OKAY, SIMPLE.
YOU CAN CHECK IT OUT.
>> IN FACT, WE WANT YOU TO STAY
HOME.
>> Shannon: YES I WOULD SAY
THAT’S THE BEST ADVICE.
LINDA GD G8 HIGH SHANNON IT’S A.
MY HUSBAND IS THE ONLY ONE IN
THE HOUSE AND WE ARE FINE AND
HEALTHY AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU HAVE A POSITIVE TEST OF
THE HOUSE, WHAT SHOULD HAVE A
BUDDY ELSE TO?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
YOU SHOULD ALSO BE IN QUARANTINE
AS WELL.
BE CAREFUL, YOU STILL WANT --
DON’T OVER INFECT OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN THE HOUSE.
THAT’S A VERY COMMON PROBLEM.
KIDS IN ONE ROOM, PARENTS AND
THE OTHER ROOM.
YOU CAN INFECT ONE ANOTHER.
SO IT’S IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE TO
BE QUARANTINED AS WE DON’T
SPREAD FROM ONE PERSON TO
ANOTHER.
AND OUTSIDE THE FAMILY AS WELL.
>> SOMEONE IS STAYING HOME AND
YOU ARE HELPING TEND TO THEM, IS
IT JUST A GIVEN THAT YOU MAKE IT
EFFECTIVE?
SHOULD BOTH OF YOU BE WEARING
MASKS?
>> IT’S REALLY TOUGH.
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS IF IT’S A
PERSON THAT SICK THAT’S
DEFINITELY BEEN DIAGNOSED, YES,
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT SHOULD BE
WEARING THE MASK.
THEY ALSO HAVE TO WEAR WHAT’S
CALLED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
IT AND CHANGE IT OFTEN AS WELL.
SO THAT YOU ARE NOT ACCIDENTALLY
CONTAMINATING YOURSELF.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
ARE THERE ANY HOME REMEDIES THAT
WILL HELP DETER THE VIRUS?
I’VE BEEN READING THAT HEAT WILL
KILL THE VIRUS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
PLEASE AND THANKS.
>> I THINK WHEN INFECTION IS
SPREADING, YOU WANTED COOL, DRY
CLIMATE.
LOTS OF HAND WASHING, HAND
SANITIZER.
LOTS OF -- WE ARE RECOMMENDING 6
THESE ARE THE IMPORTANT STEPS TO
HELP STOP THE SPREAD OF
INFECTION AND QUELL ITS
TRANSMISSION.
>> I HAVE HEARD SOME OF THIS TOO
IF YOU ARE HAVING ISSUES OR
SUFFERING FROM ANY KIND OF
RESPIRATORY THING THAT IT CAN BE
STEAMED OUT IN A HOT SHOWER.
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD PLACE TO
OPEN THINGS UP.
IS THAT THE CASE BECAUSE OF MARK
>> I DON’T THINK WE ARE SURE
YET.
WE ARE LEARNING SO MUCH ABOUT
THIS VIRUS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THEY DO IT DO THAT FOR
CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE.
HUMIDIFIER WILL BE SET UP.
CERTAINLY, THERE IS SOME
SYSTEMATIC RELIEF.
BUT I THINK YOU WILL HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL WITH HUMIDIFIERS.
THEY NEED TO BE CLEANED PROPERLY
PROPERLY.
FOR THAT REASON, I AM SUGGESTING
A FACE MASK AND THE HAND WASHING
AND THE SEPARATION.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
AND NEXT UP FROM KELLY IT SAYS
WHAT FEVER REDUCER SHOULD BE
USED FOR CORONAVIRUS?
YOU HAD MENTIONED A
ACETAMINOPHEN.
ARE THERE OTHER THINGS?
WHAT ARE THE OTHER OPTIONS?
>> I DON’T THINK IF YOU TAKE
THAT’S REALLY GONNA MAKE IT
WORSE.
AGAIN, THERE IS NO DATA OR
SCIENCE THAT SHOWS THAT THAT
ACTUALLY IS TRUE.
BUT YES, TYLENOL, ACETAMINOPHEN,
AND FLUIDS CAN DIFFERENTLY HELP
REDUCE YOUR TEMPERATURE.
AND OF COURSE REST.
AGAIN, THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS WE
DON’T WANT YOUR ILLNESS TO BE
SPREAD TO OTHER PEOPLE.
SO STAYING HOME IS A BIG ONE.
RESTING SINCE YOU ARE NOT OVER
EXERTING YOUR BODY AND NOT
PICKING UP OTHER INFECTIONS.
WE DO WORRY ABOUT OTHER
INFECTIONS AS WELL.
HAYDEN HUDSON SAID IT CAN CAUSE
KIDNEY PROBLEMS AND POTENTIAL
MATE REPRODUCTIVE PROBLEMS.
ANY TRUTH TO THIS?
>> WITH A MALE REPRODUCTION,
THERE WAS SOME QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
AND IT IS NOT IMPROVING.
WITH THE KIDNEY ISSUES, ANY TIME
A PATIENT GETS SEVERELY ILL AND
THEY CAN’T BREATHE WELL, THEIR
BLOOD PRESSURE MIGHT DROP, THEIR
KIDNEYS WILL SUFFER.
THIS IS A PATIENT WHO MIGHT EVEN
BE IN THE ICU WHO NEEDS
AGGRESSIVE REHYDRATION.
AND THEORETICALLY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CASES IN PATIENTS
WHO HAVE COVERT OR NOT THIS
THICK.
VERY QUICKLY FOR EITHER ONE OF
YOU WHO WOULD WANT TO FEEL THIS,
I’VE SEEN A LOT OF CHATTER OUT
THERE ABOUT IF WE RUN LOW ON
THESE VENTILATORS, THERE IS
MACHINES THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE
USED IN A WAY THAT WOULD IN SOME
WAY PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
VENTILATOR TYPE BENEFIT.
>> POSSIBLY.
WE ACTUALLY WOULD TURN TO
OLD-FASHIONED FLU FACTS.
OUT ON THE STREETS -- ON THE
HOMES.
WILL HOPEFULLY WE DON’T GET TO
THAT POINT.
WE ARE TRYING TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS SO THAT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE SURGE
OF PATIENTS REQUIRING
VENTILATORS BREATHING
ASSISTANCE.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BOTH OF YOUR TIME.